[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass wine at 8:00
p.m.
every once in a while don't get crazy it
makes you a better mom so pour yourself
a glass and let's talk by the way did
you see me fix the intro tonight we're
drinking rose day I bought my rose a a
little dress because one of us should be
fancy am i right I just talked to my
wine there's something I've been dying
to tell you guys but first you need a
little bit of backstory both my kids go
to daycare and they go to daycare near
where I work so I drop them off every
morning and every morning I see this
cute little lady I smile and I wave
hello and every morning she gives me
this death glare just like wow this is
cute old lady what the heck man and I
realized she's not looking at me she's
looking at my hair because I have blue
hair this is a hot topic on all the
comments and all these videos too so I
figure it's a perfect time to talk about
this let's talk about the worst things
about judgey parents so let's start off
with what that old woman was judging me
for colored hair in every video ever
that I'm in there's some commenter who
says something like oh she's a ball
she's somehow blue her my favorite color
is blue so when I dyed my hair blue it
just unlocked this whole wave of
confidence and happiness and it benefits
my kids so much more to have a happy
confident mom so any moms out there with
colored hair this one's for you
I got a wine mustache from that one next
your age I was pretty young when I had
my first and I looked very young so I
would get all these strangers I got to
park with their kids they've come up to
me and like kneel down on my sons level
and be like where's your dad
where's your dad I don't I don't know
what I got [ __ ] like Oh was he planned
Oh is he an accident
is the dad still involved who's visit
what for people who are a little bit
older they get the same thing like oh
aren't you tired oh don't you wish you
had done it earlier because you wanted a
second since when did this become your
business weird random stranger on the
sidewalk
I feel like people thought they could
ask me all these intrusive questions
because I did look young and to them the
age that they had children was the
proper time so now when I see a young
mom I will go over and be like hey you
want to come over and have some wine are
you even old enough to drink wine can I
see your ID just come on over let's have
a glass of wine next something but next
meltdowns in public I have two kids they
are four and one and a half there are
like pretty bad ages for meltdowns and
it usually always happens at the grocery
store my kids always meltdown what do
you expect it's like character [ __ ] in
every aisle we go in one aisle and it's
spider-man cereal you can't have that go
in the next aisle
it's Captain America fruit roll-ups not
buying that for you next out of there
selling Batman sugar bags just bags of
sugar with Batman on the front and so
when they do like what do you expect me
to do should I just leave my cart and
leave like we need groceries so why are
these other parents looking at me with a
disapproving look and like muttering
like she shouldn't know how kids usually
these parents are parents of children
who are well past the age of mine so
they don't really understand or seem to
remember what it was like we're not at a
movie theater you're not paying to like
enjoy this experience at the grocery
store we're all grocery shopping chill
out a little bit in this situation
parents should help each other out if
you see me at the grocery store with
both of my kids melting just take one
have it it's yours next milestones there
are certain parents it's usually like
the tiger mom type who judge your child
based on their milestones I got all this
crap with my oldest son because he was 2
and a half and he wasn't potty-trained
and there were all these other moms who
were like oh he's actually still in
port-au-prince who think that their
child should be potty trained by the age
of 6 months or something crazy like that
it's because they do this weird thing
where they hold them over the toilets
when they feel like they're about to
crap or so it's I don't even get it he's
four now and he goes to the bathroom
just fine it happens for each kid at
their own time my kids bowel movements
have nothing to do with you unless you
would like to come clean them up for me
if you can judge all you want as long as
you wipe my kids but for me next
childbirth
there is a certain subset of moms who
are gonna judge you for the way you gave
birth they'll judge you if you had an
epidural they'll judge you if you had a
c-section they'll judge you if you had a
water birth they'll judge you if you did
it at home they'll judge you if you did
it in a hospital they'll Joe to every
single part about your birth that's not
the same as the way that they gave birth
which doesn't make any sense to me
because the kids already out there's
nothing we can do about it like I can't
shove it back in and do it the way that
you thought I should have so for both of
my boys they were very short laborers it
was extremely painful and I walked right
into the hospital being like drugs drugs
drugs I got the epidural I did it in the
hospital that's where I was comfortable
and there's always that one mom who you
tell them your birth experience they're
like oh well I had mine at home with no
meds like they're better than you we
both got it out I don't care how yours
came out I don't care where you were why
do you care where mine was if I see a
baby I'm not like I wonder how it came
out of its mom's vagina I don't give a
flying hoot about the birth plan did I
just a flying hoot but the worst part
about judgy parents is that we're all
judgy parents I'm judging judgy parents
right now y'all are gonna judge me in
the comments
you are gonna judge each other in the
comments so let's just all stop we're
all on this crap rocket ride of
parenthood let's be nice to each other
if you see something that you want to
judge save it for something interesting
to tell your significant other hey guess
what I saw some dummy Todd
about judging parents she was so dumb
she had stupid hair
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah it's perfectly
acceptable to be judgy but it's not okay
to be mean that's all I got for today
I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wide mom it should be interesting to see
the comments on this video let's try to
give it nice because I read them I
appreciate them and as always if there's
anything you want me to talk about leave
it in the comments and if you have
something mean to say take that to
Twitter because I don't have a Twitter
and I don't know how to use it so till
next time
[Music]